Speaker 1: Let's go out to another interview
that is absolutely chilling.
Donald Trump says that the reporters who broke
the story on Roe v Wade getting overturned
should be jailed and forced to give up the
name of the Supreme Court leaker.
This was an interview with the right wing
Sebastian Gorka.
Hard to imagine a friendlier interviewer to
Trump, and it is just absolutely bone chilling.
Speaker 4: Catherine Engelbrecht, the heroine
and the hero of 2000 mules, her partner, Greg
Phillips, were arrested for refusing to give
up their source.
Speaker 3: How come they don't do this with
the leaker?
The leaker of the Supreme Court?
Because if you went and got to that reporter,
that's a terrible thing that happened.
It puts your justices at tremendous risk and
that continues.
So they can't find the leaker is very easy
to find the leaker.
If you did the same thing to the reporter
as you did to Catherine Engelbrecht, that's
a great woman.
You say we want to know who the leaker was
because the leaker gave the story to this
reporter.
So why aren't you doing that?
Yes.
Speaker 1: As you can see, a very healthy
respect here for freedom of the press and
independent journalists.
Now, they're lying to you, by the way.
You know, they talk about.
Oh, but other people have been other people
have been jailed when they didn't give up
their source.
The truth, the vote leaders were jailed after
being found in contempt for not complying
with the legal judicial order to identify
a believed criminal behind a data breach.
At the heart of these conspiracy claims regarding
China and our elections.
It was not about journalistic sources.
It was about identifying a criminal, a believed
criminal.
Completely different situation altogether.
Just does it does it make any sense?
Phillips and Engelbrecht declined to name
a particular individual because of the conspiratorial
belief that the guy is an FBI informant, which
is just crazy.
They're just bonkers people.
They were escorted out of a courtroom by U.S.
Marshals.
It has nothing to do with what Trump and Gorka
are talking about here.
It is a chilling attack on journalism and
independence of media.
And then Trump talks about General Mark Milley
and the infamous walk to the church.
And it's it's just insane.
Speaker 3: So Milley was weak when I heard
what he did because what he walked in with
the president, he should have said, this is
a great honor.
The president held up a Bible.
Speaker 1: And why should why should a general
praise.
A religiously tainted stunt by a president.
Why is that?
What merely has to do?
Speaker 3: We're very proud to have been in
that group.
But sickly was when when I heard him give
an apology.
They said he's gone and he was gone.
He was weak.
He was in a fannies woke.
And now I understand.
I watch him talking about white privilege
and how terrible everything is.
And, you know, it's just it's not even believable
that a guy could have gotten to that place.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Listen, anybody with a good head on their
shoulders would have seen that Bible walk
stunt where they cleared the protesters and
walked to the church.
With Trump holding up a Bible, any reasonable
person would have seen that and said.
That looks like a fascist.
I'm not saying he is one.
Or that the country has gone fascist.
But that looks like the imagery of a fascist
of totalitarianism.
It looks horrifying and we should all be against
it.
But Trump is mad that Miller didn't suck up
to him and go, Wow, sir, this was such an
amazing thing.
Scary, scary stuff.